ruinas hasta donde alcanza la vista es
todo lo que queda debajo es una ciudad
industrial de 70.000 habitantes antes de
la guerra desde este verano rusos y
ucranianos luchan encarnizadamente por
su control las fuerzas de kiev afirman
haber matado herido a más de 500
soldados enemigos en la zona en las
últimas 24 horas la batalla de bajo mud
es también una batalla de comunicación
el grupo paramilitar ruso Wagner en
primera línea de los combates Afirma
estar más cerca que nunca del centro de
la ciudad
el edificio de cinco plantas a la
derecha de donde sale el humo es el
centro administrativo de la ciudad
estamos a 1,2 kilómetros de ese edificio
Aunque la importancia estratégica debajo
Es cuestionable según los expertos
militares el Ministerio de defensa
ucraniano quiere mantener el control
sobre la ciudad con la estrategia de
concentrar los esfuerzos rusos en una
parte específica del frente es necesario
ganar tiempo para acumular reservas y
lanzar una contraofensiva en la
primavera que está por llegar Aunque
bajo desde el centro de atención la
guerra también continúa en el sur de
Ucrania este sábado en gerson un ataque
ruso mató a tres personas e hirió a
otras dos